you're working at zagat you're fact
checking your signature dishing
you have your illustrious acting career
in the rearview mirror
where are you at and what brings you
back see i would say my illustrious
acting career was in
was was ahead of me at that point
because what was behind me was was not
my choice right but like in front of me
was living in new york going to see
broadway shows all the time standing in
the tkts line and getting you know and
getting to see broadway and that was um
that was when it really started um you
know kind of the
the jiminy cricket on my shoulder saying
you should you should try this again i'm
like yeah but was that the only voice
that told you to go back to acting um so
i was there was like a for about a month
i was getting these
signs from just you know the universe
would call the synchronicity you know
and yeah i met roberta flack at a nail
salon
and just wacky and then and i met her
and she and she asked what i was doing i
said i'm done with show business and she
looked at me like i had seven heads and
she was like why you know why would you
not or you know and um so it it just
stuck with me and then and then
like the straw that brought the camel's
back was i was on a lunch break crying
because you cry on a lunch break when
you're sad and in your 20s sometimes and
i'm
um
um towards madison avenue to get a
burger and there was a a psychic who was
always like handing out her pamphlets on
53rd in madison and she was you know oh
i you know i have a question for you and
i'm like yeah yeah that's that's what
you say that's what you say to advertise
and she followed me
and
um she she not uh poked on my shoulder i
turn around um you know a mess and she's
like i have a question i'm like what she
says are you the girl for my girl i'm
like ugh yes
and
you know great psychic and so then
but then she says um
then she said
you're not done you still want to do
this
and i you know then i was like oh i mean
it was it was ten it was
forty dollars for a ten minute palm
reading
on my lunch break on an editorial
assistant salary 40 on a lunch break
really like meant a lot to me but i but
i did i got my palm read and um
and but really the message was and you
know you you need to try this again you
uh you know you
you aren't done you're wondering if you
need to try and so that stuck with me i
i yeah
and
you saw this like well you
you there's a
pack of tarot cards here
how did this come about you read tarot
cards i do this is you know this is
yours it's later now today 20 hours
later i this you know so i i do i
um how do i start i i
first saw my first decatero i think my
dad brought it into the house because he
was exploring our roma uh heritage where
um
that's our heritage which is always very
connected with with psychics and tarot
and you know dancing bears and whatever
and we have that in our heritage too um
and then i didn't look at it for a long
long time and then i was in a play
in 2018
at second stage with an actor named
stephen park who reads tarot
and so we got used to like every day
just pulling a card
and once that show was over and he was
no longer in my life every day with his
card i missed it and i learned and i
learned
[Music]
you